[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avant d'imaginer le futur de
l'université plongeons-nous peut-être
dans son passé nos archives universités
j'ai découvert ce magnifique manuscrit
qui datent de 1652
il s'agit en fait d'un d'un cours de
logique
écrit par un étudiant qui s'appelle
cornelius qui est un étudiant en
première année en faculté de la cud et
des arts ont été du louvre est donc en
1652 comment se déroulait la formation
universitaire là pour à court de logique
cornelius devait avant chaque cours
recopier sous dans ce manuscrit
mot-à-mot la matière du court ensuite
dans un deuxième temps dans un auditoire
le professeur enseigne et la matière
devant les étudiants et ils discutaient
ensemble des éléments de cette matière
pour secours de logique
voyons un petit peu en 1652 rapport
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui a évolué la
prenons par exemple domaine de
l'écriture dans le domaine de l'écriture
c'est la plume d'oie
c'est 1852 c'est le tout début de la de
la poste réservé à une élite l'écriture
est aujourd'hui aujourd'hui tout le
monde un smartphone et on peut
communiquer avec n'importe qui dans le
monde entier de manière quasi
instantanée
en 1652 et c'est aussi le tout début des
transports publics
hervé encore à une élite ont voyagé à
peu près à 1 8 km heure non pas très
rapides et aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
plupart des personnes peuvent prendre
l'avion peut voyager d'un continent à
l'autre à une vitesse d'environ 900 km
heure soit plus de 100 fois plus rapides
qu'en 1652 essayons maintenant de
comparer le monde de la formation
universitaire de 1652 et d'aujourd'hui
bien sûr universités en 1152 était
réservée à une élite intellectuelle
aujourd'hui les universités font face à
une massification et une démocratisation
de l'enseignement mais les choses ont
elles changé
vous avez à gauche la situation en 1652
où il avait à droite
la situation d'aujourd'hui les méthodes
d'enseignement elle beaucoup changé
pas vraiment le numérique aujourd'hui
bouleverse pendant le monde de la
formation
quelles sont les technologies comment
peut-on les utiliser et quelle
université numérique
souhaitons nous prenons un exemple
l'exemple des mousses il s'agit de
massives open online corps 6
c'est-à-dire de cours qui vous est suivi
par n'importe qui gratuitement librement
dans le monde entier à son propre rythme
aujourd'hui dans le monde il ya environ
9400 mousse disponible est à peu près 80
millions d'inscrits sur l'année 2010 est
qu en est il dans notre université en
notre université offrait 25 mx savez
vous que depuis 14 ans 25 le nombre
d'étudiants qui ont été accueillis par
l'ue s'est elle est de 500 mille cinq
cent mille étudiants ont à peu près 600
ans en 2017
25 mx combien d'inscrits dans ces moux
en quarante cinq mille inscriptions bien
sûr s'inscrire un moule c'est pas la
même chose que de suivre une formation
université d'accord la comparaison n'est
pas toujours correctes mais néanmoins ce
chiffre est quand même assez
interpellant aujourd'hui le savoir est
disponible en quelques clics sur sur
google sur wikipédia sur les moux à quoi
ça sert pour étudiants d'aller passer
deux heures dans un auditoire écouter un
professeur alors que le temps
d'attention de l'étudiant et de six
minutes
pourquoi ne pas remplacer les cours
universitaires par des mix à quoi
servent les professeurs les campus
universitaires sont ils nécessaires
l'université était en train de mourir
répondre à ces questions c'est en fait
prédire l'avenir
imaginez les technologies du futur est
quelque chose d'extrêmement difficile on
va prendre un petit exemple que vous
connaissez peut-être le film blade
runner succès de science-fiction 1982
l'action se déroule en 2019 quasiment
aujourd'hui et dans ce monde imaginé
il y à des robots qu'on appelle des
réplicants extrêmement sophistiqué
tellement réaliste que notre héros
harrison ford tombe amoureux d'une
réplicante comment fait-il
harrison forte pour prendre rendez vous
avec la réplique quand ils utilisent un
téléphone public avec des pièces de
monnaie en termes d' imagination du
futur on peut pas dire que ce soit une
grande réussite
nous allons maintenant envisager trois
technologies qui je pense vont avoir une
influence importante dans le monde de la
formation universitaire la première
c'est la réalité virtuelle et réalité
augmentée
imaginez un cours d'astronomie dans
lequel vous vous baladez dans le système
solaire en cours de biologie dans lequel
vous êtes au coeur du corps humain pour
comprendre son fonctionnement
imaginez un laboratoire de physique
virtuel une opération chirurgicale qui
aura retrait de faire virtuellement
parlant la deuxième technologie
ce sont les appareils mobiles bien sûr
une technologie standard mais pour
l'apprentissage
les limites sont extraordinaires en
effet le téléphone mobile d device
mobile vous permettent d'accéder à tout
moment aux savoirs ainsi qu aux
dispositifs d'apprentissage
imaginez dans quelques années vous aurez
une voiture avec un conducteur qui sera
un ordinateur que ferez vous pendant le
trajet pourquoi pas apprendre et que
votre device mobile la troisième
technologie c'est l'intelligence
artificielle il existe beaucoup
d'implication d'avoir un officiel pour
la formation juste prendre un seul
exemple pour un cours online un
professeur de georgia tech aux états
unis a choisi de remplacer deux de ses
dix assistants par des robots rappel des
tchats bottes dont l'objectif est de
répondre aux questions des apprenants à
votre avis que s'est il passé
les apprenants n'ont rien vu ils n'ont
pas pu détecter que deux des assistants
étaient en fait des tchats bottes cette
chatte bottes
ap abl de répondre à des questions de
base sur une matière scientifique
l'objectif n'est pas de remplacer le
professeur ou les assistants l'objectif
de leur permettre de consacrer leur
temps à des tâches à une plus haute
valeur ajoutée que de répondre à des
questions de base voudrait maintenant
vous présenter quatre émergence pour
l'université numérique
la première émergence c'est la formation
multimodal il s'agit donc d'utiliser
plusieurs mode d'apprentissage au sein
d'une même formation
prenons un exemple qu'on appelle les
classes inversée mais il s'agit par
exemple pour les étudiants d'apprendre
une partie de la matière via un mou une
partie de mou et ensuite d'avoir un
travail de groupe entre étudiants ou
d'avoir une séance en audit war avec le
professeur pour répondre à des questions
ou faire une étude de cas dans cette
approche multimodale le rôle du
professeur évolué le professeur and
trans n'est pas le savoir ils
l'accompagnent
l'étudiant dans son apprentissage dans
cet apprentissage multimodal les
interactions entre apprenants et avec le
professeur sont essentiels des
interactions se déroule sur le campus
les campus universitaires vont donc
rester un lieu actifs d'apprentissage la
deuxième émergents ce que je voudrais
vous montrez est illustrée par cette
fresque de philadelphie ont le titre et
lifelong learning apprentissage tout au
long de la vie
l'université doit s'adapter elle doit
offrir des programmes ainsi que des
méthodes d'apprentissage adaptés à ce
public aujourd'hui 10% des lions
d'université ont plus 30 ans ce
pourcentage va croître de manière très
rapide au cours des prochaines années
troisième émergence
c'est l'aspect modulaire de
l'apprentissage
il s'agit pour l'apprenant de pouvoir
construire son programme d'études à la
manière de briques lego qu'on assemble
avec des briques de différents types
pour pouvoir par exemple combiné des
cours universitaires des certificats
obtenus par des mousses et de
l'expérience professionnelle et enfin
quatrième émergence vous connaissez
wikipédia est une encyclopédie
collaborative libre et gratuite dans le
monde de la formation les ressources
éducationnelles libres permettent aux
enseignants de diffuser leurs sources et
permet aux apprenants de pouvoir
utiliser dans le monde entier les
ressources disponibles
en résumé l'université numérique doit
être multimodal doit être adaptée à la
formation tout au long de la vie elle
doit être modulaire et l'université doit
inciter les enseignants à déposer leurs
ressources pédagogiques de manière libre
à l'ensemble du monde
si nous demandions à cornelius de
revenir parmi nous aujourd'hui entre
1650 2 est aujourd'hui 2018 quelle
serait sa réaction
bien sûr il serait surpris par
l'évolution technologique par
l'utilisation des technologies dans la
formation comme les moux mais en fait il
se dirait que l'objectif de l'université
ils restent inchangés c'est-à-dire
former des femmes et des hommes capables
de penser capable de transformer la
société est capable de la porter je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]